the answer to basically everything is to
earn more earning like ridiculously high
returns from your Investments is really
hard and very few people can do it
consistently and the reason you've heard
of the people who can like Warren
Buffett is because there aren't many of
them so you can earn like a certain
amount of return but you got pushing
that boundary is hard there's only so
much you can save you know you can cut
to the Bone but you can't save Beyond
zero so it's like there's only so much
so what the variable you're left with is
earning and so it's spending more time
thinking about earning is the best thing
that people can do and that can be a
side business a care business or that
kind of thing it could also be just be
having a more intentional approach to
your
career